We’ve all dreamed of world peace at one
time or another.
Cynics might say that total, uninterrupted
peace on a global scale is something that
could never be achieved.
Wars, crime, unstable political relationships,
international tension; as long as human beings
have the capacity for these things, they will
remain as obstacles standing in the way of
world peace.
And then there’s all the SCPs and dangerous
anomalies out there.
Just the existence of half the horrors contained
by the SCP Foundation could easily bring about
the end of the entire world as we know it,
and it’s hard to achieve peace when death
and destruction could be right around the
corner.
But what if that wasn’t the case?
What if there was no end of the world scenario;
no evil eldritch god pulling the strings above,
and no catastrophe waiting to finally drop?
What if the world was just… safe?
If an existence of perfect peace and harmony
still sounds like a pipe dream to you, then
perhaps you should join us on a trip into
the unknown, a journey into a world where
things are so much better than here.
Welcome to SCP-6001, welcome to Avalon.
A safer and more peaceful world has always
been, at least partly, the goal of the SCP
Foundation.
And it is true that, without their containment
and understanding of anomalous objects, the
world would be a far more dangerous place
- if it wasn’t completely destroyed in its
entirety.
However, there is always more that the Foundation
could do with their vast resources to improve
the world.
There are even SCPs that they have contained
whose anomalous abilities could greatly benefit
all of mankind, but the organization would
hardly ever approve of doing anything like
that, right?
Well, SCP-6001 is a universe in which that
actually happened, or rather something similar
happened.
Here, the resources of an organization like
the Foundation were put to better use, and
ultimately created a utopia, a paradise for
all, achieving what we referred to at the
start of this video: World peace.
The entry for SCP-6001 on the SCP Archive
opens with an email addressed to us from a
member of Foundation personnel called David
Caspian, that reads:
“Hey, sorry, I know it's late, but I just
had to share this with someone, and there's
no one in the world I'd rather share it with
than you.
I just had the most incredible day.”
Then, as the article continues, there are
numerous format changes from the standard
SCP Foundation entries that we’re familiar
with.
In particular, the typical terminology is
vastly altered from what we’d be familiar
with.
The term “SCP” is now “Phenom”, “Special
Containment Procedures” has been replaced
with “Modus”, “Imprimis” takes the
place of “Description” and even the name
of the organization is different: the Compendium
Phenomic Inquiry.
This appears to be a version of the SCP Foundation
that exists in some kind of parallel universe
or alternate timeline to The Foundation that
we know.
Phenom-6001 itself is a tiny, microscopic
singularity uncovered in the Tokyo of this
other universe’s Japan.
This singularity is linked to another version
of Tokyo from another universe, which is referred
to as A6K.
This universe, A6K, is described by the Compendium
as being similar to their own reality, in
almost every superficial and surface level
way.
It looks the same, contains the same people,
the same places, and even the same anomalies,
but that is where the similarities end.
The A6K universe diverges from this baseline
by having a general lack of cooperation among
its inhabitants, scientific repression along
with heightened paranoia, aggression, and
levels of violence.
Sound familiar?
It should, because A6K’s main scientific
institution is a group known as the SCP Foundation.
That’s right, A6K is the Foundation’s
reality.
The Foundation is aware of what it refers
to as SCP-6001, but because of the tiny size
of the singularity that links their world
with that of the Compendium, none of their
personnel are able to travel through to that
reality.
The Compendium states that it is considering
unifying with the Foundation, striking up
an alliance between universes.
However, they both have dramatically different
approaches which would likely get in the way
of that.
The SCP Foundation has always been shrouded
in secrecy, never revealing anything to the
public, often eliminating or memory wiping
anyone who witnesses an anomaly just to keep
everything under wraps.
Meanwhile, in their universe, the CPI has
willingly made its documents and anomalous
information available to anyone that asks
for it.
In the Foundation’s reality, the world they
were linked to via SCP-6001 was seemingly
first discovered when David Caspian, the personnel
member we mentioned earlier, hunched over
the spot where the singularity was located
for almost five minutes.
He had been doing this for a number of weeks
since the Foundation’s instruments first
detected the existence of the tiny hole connecting
A6K with another dimension.
David’s focus had been so fixated on the
spot where SCP-6001 was, that it wasn’t
until he got back up that he realized he was
in a completely different universe.
He described tall, rounded skyscrapers unlike
the Tokyo of the Foundation’s world, gigantic
ivy growing up the buildings with leaves the
size of cars.
The clouds above had been replaced with the
clearest blue sky, and clean, fresh air took
the place of the stale, polluted environment
David had just left.
A nearby cat was perched on the same rooftop
as David, watching strange, seed-shaped glass
constructs floating on the horizon, filled
with lush green innards.
The cat had a coat of spotted orange, white
and brown, underneath an actual coat, a violet
blazer, complete with a white bow under the
collar and a black brooch pinned to it; the
shape of an eye inside a globe.
It even wore a pair of spectacles.
The cat, Primrose, greeted David by name and
introduced herself, the pair sharing a brief
joke about “stepping through the looking
glass.”
Both of them were doctors.
In fact, David was the Foundation’s Head
of Alt-Dimensional Research.
When he asked Primrose how he’d arrived
on her side of SCP-6001, she responded by
asking if he had heard of something called
cross-dimensional test sampling.
Of course, David was more than familiar with
it, not only was it a standard procedure for
the SCP Foundation, but one that he himself
had written.
The procedure involved bringing an isolated
part of another reality to a safe environment
within one’s own for testing purposes.
This is exactly what the Compendium had done
to bring David to their universe.
According to Primrose, the Compendium had
many similar procedures to the Foundation,
causing David to ask why, if this was the
case, he wasn’t being scanned or checked
for contaminants and pathogens, or paralysed
to prevent kinetographic memetics.
Primrose responded by simply asking if he
had eaten breakfast and seemingly inviting
him to Paris.
Primrose then sat with David on an armchair
on the Tokyo rooftop and spoke an address
to it.
The next moment, she and David were transported
to Paris, in a courtyard filled with similar
chairs that other people and animals were
using to teleport.
Primrose referred to them as The Everywhere
Chair, a form of public transport.
David remarked that there was something similar
in the A6K universe, referring to SCP-1609,
which was destroyed by the Global Occult Coalition.
The cat responded by saying that David would
find many similarities between their universes
and mentioned that she was the Department
Head of Trans-Dimensional Development and
Discovery for the CPI.
But then, Primrose declared she no longer
wanted to discuss work as she was already
off the clock despite it only being the early
hours of the morning.
When David questioned this, Primrose replied
“The wonders of automation, David.
More hands make less work, and we have a lot
of hands.
Besides, I've something more important lined
up for today.”
She then ordered Oeufs Brouillés from a holographic
menu, and David ordered the same, remarking
“When in Rome – or Paris – or a parallel
reality with talking cats – you do as the
Romans.”
David then asked Primrose about the Compendium,
learning it was a primarily scientific institute
but that it lacked the employees of the SCP
Foundation.
Primrose and her fellow researchers were under
no obligation to work for the CPI, but rather
were able to choose to work with them out
of their own curiosity or interest.
The Compendium was also responsible for running
the governments, economies, and law enforcement
of the entire world, with Primrose likening
the organization to “benevolent dictators”.
David then expressed surprise that people
didn’t resist the Compendium taking control
of the world, to which his feline counterpart
replied:
“Goodness no.
Governments?
Certainly.
Corporations?
Absolutely.
The people though?
Imagine a foreign power suddenly swooping
in and saying ‘Hey there.
So, we're in charge now.
Here's universal healthcare, living wages,
housing, infrastructure, and total liberty
from anyone but us - and literally all we
ask of you is to respect basic human rights.
That's it.
We provide the rest, tax-free.
This also includes ethically replicated BBQ,
instant global transport, and adorable talking
animals.
Also, the cure to cancer.’
Can you really think of anyone so wedded to
existing power structures that they'd just
say no to all that?”
It’s easy to see why people would willingly
accept something so universally beneficial.
By the time the Compendium had gone public,
they had already been working with world governments
in the shadows much like the SCP Foundation.
At first, the public response had been rough,
but all it took was a few years of human life
on Earth improving to help the naysayers change
their tune.
Partway through their meal, David and Primrose
discussed the Compendium further.
She revealed that something called PACT-15
was currently in the process of being rolled
out worldwide.
PACT stood for Phenom Application and/or Combination
Technology, phenoms being the CPI’s term
for an SCP or anomaly.
The initiative had come about after the Compendium
studied an Australian talking spider, or SCP-1470
as David knew it.
The goal of PACTs was to find a use for phenoms
that would not only benefit the people of
their universe, but would also benefit the
phenoms themselves.
These creatures, objects, and entities were
all given the freedom to choose whether or
not they complied, and those that did would
find their existence to be bliss.
David was given a tour of Primrose’s world,
encountering all manner of familiar SCPs that
had been repurposed and allowed to live their
best possible lives alongside human beings,
living in uninterrupted peace.
For example, Dr. Clef seemingly pulled off
the impossible by finally curing 682 of its
aggression, shortly after finding a whole
nest of the creatures.
682’s species, dubbed the Immortigons, have
since both proliferated and really mellowed
out, with the OG 682 stating that it no longer
finds humans disgusting.
Another nightmarish anomaly from David’s
universe, SCP-173, the Sculpture, has found
a new lease on life in this world, too.
It lives in a museum, being adored by everyone
who sees it, and it uses a mere second of
being unseen every night to reshape itself
into a new beautiful construction.
Turns out, a lot of its aggression merely
came from being confined.
As a piece of art, it wanted to be looked
at and loved, not locked away and feared.
Meanwhile, however, the various groups that
formed the Compendium Phenomic Inquiry were
casting their votes on what was to be done
about the residents of dimension A6K; what
would they do about The Foundation?
Some among the Compendium saw the people of
their neighboring universe as prisoners, needing
liberation.
Groups known as the Wanderers and the Charity
hoped to save universe A6K, to heal a world
in need of their help.
After all, this universe had the means to
cure diseases, end famines, and ultimately
achieve total peace, and wanted to share their
gifts with the Foundation’s world.
However, one by one opposing votes were cast.
Other groups, like the Synthetic Assembly,
looked to how A6K treated machines like slaves,
refusing them their own free agency.
Another, known as the Partnership of Three
argued that A6K held no value.
“Their natural resources deplete at a staggering
rate.
Their labor force is sickly and untrained.
Their cultural dissimilarities are… well,
laughable.
We have everything they have – and what
little uniqueness they bring to market, so
to speak, isn’t worth its counter space.
They wouldn’t even make a good tourist trap!
What kind of morbid SOB would want to visit
these “wonders" of theirs?
It's all tombs and constructs of war, old
crumbling architecture where people would
fight each other to the death for sport…
and who defaces a perfectly good mountain
like that with a bunch of dead people's faces!?!
Some of the Compendium claimed that the people
of universe A6K had to learn to overcome their
own adversities, rather than the easy option,
for their universe’s people coming in to
fix everything.
Others simply claimed that A6K was just irredeemable,
its people not to be trusted.
Finally, the vote was settled, the Compendium
would deny help to the Foundation and its
universe, and would seal SCP-6001 just enough
to keep them out.
But they would watch over A6K, and the day
when the people of that universe were ready
to come and ask for the Compendium’s help,
the day they were ready to finally know world
peace, they would be welcomed with open arms.
Needless to say, that day hasn’t arrived
yet.
We just really, really hope it does some time
soon.
One person however, did get a happy ending
in this story: None other than David himself,
who now works blissfully in a bar in alternate
Osaka.
We’d love to be happy for him, but frankly,
we’re a little too jealous.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - When Day Breaks”
and “SCP-001 Ouroboros Cycle - The Full
Story Compilation” for more alternate universe
craziness!